hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm joined once again by team edge
Ryan and Matt of course and we're going
to be doing the drunk water balloon go
through this giant bouncy castle that we
rented for this particular video
challenge see what what we literally
rented a giant bouncy castle just cuz we
could and we're gonna do a video why not
we have drunk goggles there alcohol is
we have drunk goggles and if you've ever
had these on they make it really hard to
see so what we're going to be doing is
each team member individually is going
to be going through with these while the
other guys are going to be pelting us
with water balloons and our time is
timed and then add to our team's time
and then the team time between the two
teams is going to be compared between
the teen times between games got it cool
all right
the college team time whoever has less
yeah whoever's less time so easy quit
Oh
okay are you gonna go this way now
that's so hard cuz I was like flinching
to get out of the water balloons that I
got I smacked in the face it moved the
goggles cuz water head have the goggles
Billy go up and down it is now
Brian's turn good luck Brian team edge
am i right Mitch
go
Oh
keep going what you're lighting the
water come on dude come on
you
that is so much harder than its way oh
so it's gonna be more and more
challenging the farther this race goes
because the slides getting more wet
which means it's harder to get traction
going up all right make your way into
the butthole
whoa what the heck
oh dude he's like the best these are
talking oh that's way more painful than
it looks
yeah
Wow
so rusty where my Sacco all right you
got this you got this good move that is
hungry two one
whoa put the goggles on
hey I did it
what's the fastest time holy crap dude
he just went flying down yeah both times
he he came back down and just went boom
Oh blimey
okay I couldn't get back up that day cuz
I didn't have my sauce that's the new
record dang
alright so that was the water balloon
castle a dodging drunk challenge where
we we are team Team Lord minion 777 won
by 6 seconds so thank you me much for
joining us and thank you man pulling it
out Wow Ryan now it's impressive hey
Skye we do we did another challenge with
this bouncy castle over on t matches
channel check it out in the description
and we have a lot of fun there we'll see
who wins then the rematch thank you and
as always we'll see you in the next
video bye